[Music]
joining me today is the editor of spiked
online and a true free speech warrior
Brendan O'Neil finally welcome to the
Reuben reply day I've been trying to get
you for like a year and a half
you are not on Twitter what kind of
human in 2017 public and hers in editor
is I hate her I hate Twitter I think
it's become incredibly toxic yeah
and it's become it was supposed to be a
tool of free speech where you could
express yourself and say what you think
and maybe even a space on the internet
for people who have different crazy or
alternative views but in many ways
that's become the opposite it's become a
tool for shutting down free speech you
know the whole twitch phenomenon Twitter
mobs anyone who thinks outside of the
kind of mainstream liberal PC box can be
hounded quite easily yeah so I'm not a
fan of Twitter also I have a short
temper oh they do really doing the right
side I think I'd be suited to Twitter
because I would end up getting two
arguments I didn't want to get into yeah
for a free speech guy in and an
absolutist in this regard the mobs and
all that and the twitch policing and all
of that you're for them doing all that I
said you're not for stopping them doing
those things just talking about the
process yeah everyone doing all the
stuff yeah it's a difficult one because
you don't want any clamp down or
restrictions on their right to be a mob
right you want to defend the right to
form a mob and to say things as a mob
but it is it does have an impact on
freedom of speech and freedom of thought
and it's the point John Stuart Mill
makes in on Liberty John Stuart Mill
often argued that the worst kind of
censorship is not necessarily legal or
state censorship it's often what he
called the informal tyranny of custom
where there's just this expectation that
you will go along with the conformist
mainstream view and if you don't you
will in some subtle way be punished
maybe acid from polite society may be a
signal will be sent that you're not a
good person
I think the Twitter mob from phenomenon
feeds into that so in many ways it can
be a more insidious form of censorship
than even government censorship yeah
it's so interesting cuz I say all the
time now it's that at the moment and of
course this can change but at the moment
I'm not that concerned about
government censorship at the moment that
being said what I am concerned about is
that we're silencing ourselves really
because everyone is afraid of the
outrage machine and that's why I've
tried to consistently bring on people
like you who although you're not on
Twitter who are just out there doing it
and you're still alive and as Douglas
Murray said to me the water ain't that
cold you guys get out there and do it
yeah I think the worst kind of
censorship now is self censorship almost
cowardice is a strong word I think with
some people it's a cowardice of about
saying what they really think other
people with other people who said
genuine genuine fear that if they say
what they think they will be hounded or
demonized and so on self censorship is
the real danger now and there's a lot of
it going on people who are not speaking
freely and openly because they fear the
consequences and the consequences can be
quite severe you can have your workplace
hounded with email saying you should
sack this guy because he thinks a B or C
of course you can be hounded off campus
by informal gangs of feminists or PC
people or or even trans people the
government has no involvement in that
but it does nonetheless have this very
insidious profound impact on the general
freedom of society and the general sense
that everything should be sable
everything should be debatable
everything should be up for discussion
that idea is being demolished not by
government jackboots but increasingly by
these informal gangs of PC enforcers
yeah where do you think that the
companies themselves the tech companies
so Facebook Twitter YouTube etc what
responsibilities do they have because
everyone knows they have their own Terms
of Service nobody we're putting this on
YouTube nobody's forcing me to be on
YouTube nobody's forcing me to be on
Twitter again you're not on Twitter a
wise man but what responsibilities
related to free speech do you think they
have because they've booted off some
people yeah that I think are actually DC
I'm not talking about some of the you
know people that are actually making
death threats which of course is a legal
issue but they put some people like
sargon of akkad i've had on my show a
couple times they've booted him off
twitter i think they have a large
responsibility in relation to freedom of
speech and there was a Supreme Court
case in this country decades ago about
corporate towns which are these towns
bill
tap around corporations and so on and
one of these corporate towns are a few
of these corporate towns argued that
they didn't have to adhere to the First
Amendment because they were private
entities and the judgment that was made
in the Supreme Court case was that if
you are a private enterprise which is so
large that you legitimately incorporate
a huge amount of public space a huge
amount of the public sphere in which
people speak and which in which people
interact then you do actually have a
responsibility to defend freedom of
speech and I think that certainly goes
for social media companies yeah that's
interesting that's now the that's now a
public arena that's the if you look at
Facebook like a seventh of humanity is
on Facebook or Twitter millions of
people on Twitter millions and millions
of people on YouTube these are the new
public forums these are the new public
squares these are the new spaces in
which people stand up make
pronouncements get on soap boxes hand
out pamphlets engage their fellow
citizens so I think it's entirely
legitimate to expect that the same free
speech that we hope would apply in a
public square would apply in these
forums too so is there a little bit of a
problem there because we're going to
talk about your your Marxist libertarian
views in a little bit but as someone
that at least going off the second part
of that the libertarian side I know for
me the idea of having the government
come in and now tell Facebook and
YouTube
what to do even though I had my
frustrations with them I don't really
see that as the answer here what I see
is the answer is capitalism in a
competition and let other companies come
and hopefully you know give a little
competition so they have to give us a
better service but but I struggle with
this one and interestingly I see a lot
of people on the right who were supposed
to be the libertarians and limited
government guys calling for these places
to be regulated you know sort of like
they did to AT&T a year you know years
ago yeah it's a difficult one because on
the one hand you don't want the
government to tell these social media
companies to prevent people from saying
certain things which is happening in
Britain at the moment lots of
politicians are kind of ganging together
to force Twitter and other forums to
restrict certain things in a speech and
so on so you don't want that but on the
other hand you don't necessarily want
the government to force these companies
to preserve freedom of speech or
publish things that they might not want
to publish Nathan private organization
so it is difficult there's no question
about that but my preference would be
that we would encourage these kind of
companies and encourage social media
platforms to value freedom of speech in
its entirety which means freedom of
speech not only for people who we like
and who are agreeable and who are
interesting and sensible and and and
liberal and nice and so on but also for
people who are edgy and difficult and
controversial and contrary in' and maybe
even hateful on the basis that is only
by having the fullest freedom of
expression possible that we can all then
work out what we think is right and
wrong but you know that's the only
possibility of having of arriving at any
kind of truth where everything is up for
grabs everything is stated publicly and
then you trust the audience you trust
the viewers you trust the listeners to
decide for themselves using their
autonomous minds what's good and what's
bad that's the kind of culture we need
to cultivate yeah is there a doubly
difficult problem here because also we
don't know what's going on with the
algorithms that these companies make so
publicly they could say we're for free
speech yes all these things but actually
they might be writing in code that could
you know stop some of my subscribers
from seeing videos or putting me aside
could you know wipe out people's Twitter
accounts or whatever does it's like we
actually don't know now the math behind
how people get information
unquestionably that happens and I don't
I don't have a Twitter account but I
sometimes look at to it so you can't
live in the modern sphere without
looking at it and seeing what people are
talking about on there and what amazes
me if you look at Twitter stories for
example all the things that Twitter
emphasizes it's always stuff that goes
along with the Twitter mindset with
Silicon Valley mindset with that kind of
fairly mainstream conformist mindset now
you know they they emphasize the if
Twitter has a kind of intersectional
outburst and it attacks someone for
being sexist on the sojanet or racist
and so on often overblown accusations
Twitter will emphasize that up
and turn it into the daily story so
Twitter undoubtedly has an editorial
input and control and in a sense you
want to say fine that's you can do that
but then they've got to stop calling
themselves the free speech wing of the
Free Speech Party because increasingly
they do appear like a publication just
happens to let other voices chip in
every now and then so basically what I'm
sensing from you is that there really is
no good answer here yet right because
what you're saying is you want them to
self-police you don't want the
government to come in you want them to
be transparent but you don't want to use
force to make that strap in so there
really is no answer that we can walk
away from and be like well alright
that's the sensible way to deal with it
that's not the idea that you're talking
about that way yeah I like the personal
responsibility of the individual and the
company but that's sort of separate from
what actually happens when the rubber
meets the road
yeah there's no easy answer except that
we should defend freedom of speech every
single time it's under attack whether
that's in the Academy on some informal
part of campus in relation to the
government in social media in the press
wherever freedom of speech is under
attack we should defend freedom of
speech and we should defend it for the
very simple reason that everyone should
be allowed to say what they want to say
and everyone else this is the part of
freedom of speech that people forget
because they always say oh you're
defending free speech for horrible
people
the second even more important part of
freedom of speech is defending the right
of the audience to decide for themselves
what's right and what's wrong yeah and
that's the most important part because
the problem with censorship of course is
that it infantilizes people in tells you
you don't have to think we will think
for you we will decide for you and that
really weakens people's moral muscles
weakens their intellectual muscle
muscles encourages them to be child like
an infant like and and to never think
about the world yeah if it directly
feeds out raid culture it actually feeds
a if it's a very simplistic reader of
the world a very childish reading of the
world and it dumbs down culture
censorship is a far greater threat to
intellectualism and peace and liberty
and all those things we think are good
then freedom of speech ever could be so
it's important to always defend freedom
of speech in every sphere and through
doing that I think we might eventually
encourage people rather than forcing
them to protect freedom of speech within
the spheres in which they operate yeah
do you think we're getting some wins
right now I mean I you're doing a tour
with a bunch of people from Brett
Weinstein and Laura Kipnis and Steven
Pinker and a whole bunch of people in
this space and you know I'm doing the
college thing too and obviously spiked
is working this show is working other
people in this plate in this space it's
all working do you think we're actually
starting to win here I'm you know I'm
hopeful as a human yeah I know I'm an
optimist yeah otherwise I couldn't do
this but there's so much bad stuff it's
hard to it's hard to place it I there
between optimism and pessimism and which
are both valuable emotions as it happens
optimism is good because you feel
buoyant and you want to go out and fight
in the world and pessimism is good
because it makes you reflect and think
well what's going wrong so I don't have
a problem with either of those takes but
I flip between the two on the one hand
I'm optimistic because I see lots of
young people and on this tall that
spiders doing the unsafe space tour
whether they're on two campuses and what
we're trying to do in fact is move away
from the pantomime debates that have
been taking place on campus in recent
years where some member of the so-called
alright we'll come in and irritate all
the feminists and the idiots in the
audience and then they will you know the
alt-right gets a kick because they wind
everyone up and then the audience
members get a kick butt because they get
to shout fascist at people they don't
right and all you do is strengthen the
extreme you straighten these dreams and
it's all heat and no light and it's
entertaining and everyone watches on
YouTube and it gets hundreds of
thousands of hits but no one learns
anything so what we're trying to do with
this tour is go onto campuses and and
convince people using hopefully
intellectual rigor and and substantial
historical arguments and and clever
people yeah that freedom of speech is
the most important value in a civilized
society and in fact civilized society is
not possible without it so we're trying
as best as we can to
the discussion away from the rather
pantomime black and white unhelpful
clash that it's become the cultural war
that it's become to explain the origins
of freedom and the importance of freedom
and I'm optimistic because we've were
having a good reception and I'm meeting
young people in New York and Washington
and and other places in America who are
really really keen on freedom of speech
but feel like they don't have a place in
which they can say how keen they are on
freedom of speech yeah so I'm optimistic
in that sense I'm pessimistic in the
sense that I fear that the argument of
freedom is being colonized by people on
the right who I don't think are always a
hundred percent convincing in their
defense of freedom and the thing that
particularly worries me now is the
left's abandonment of the ideal of
freedom I think that's actually the real
crisis we face in Western societies now
which is that the left and so-called
liberals and you know the word liberal
is about the word liberty you know are
turning their backs on Liberty that's a
real problem yeah okay so I really want
to dive deep into this one because
everyone watching this at least my
audience knows that I mean this is where
I've spent most of my time you know I
came from the progressive world I wanted
to fix the left subsequently two years
later after endlessly talking about this
I did a video with Prager you which day
titled why I left left because I've come
to the position that liberalism in the
classical sense the John Stuart Mill
sense no longer has anything to do with
modern leftism yeah so let's really go
deeper yeah so first off let's start
with why are you let's start with the
roots of why liberalism should be
connected to the left let's just start
there
well the way I put it is that I didn't
leave the left the left left me because
the left abandoned everything that it
used to represent and the way I see
political correctness which is this kind
of rehabilitation of the racial
imagination so everyone is now black and
white or man and woman in this constant
divisive nurse and shoving people back
into biological boxes from which they
spent 200 years trying to escape or it's
a liberalism so it doesn't want you to
be
controversial or daring or contrarian
what's everything to be sedate or even
the modern PC people's agitation with
things like economic growth or exploring
nature or even dare I say exploiting
nature for the good of mankind on all
occasions right I mean that's super
controversial yeah all those things
suggest to me that the PC culture you
know people call it left in my mind it
runs counter to everything the left used
to stand for I think it is reactionary I
think if anything is right-wing I happen
to think left and right aren't
particularly useful the categories now
but it's certainly more right wing than
it is left wing do you might remember a
moment when it happened because that's
what a lot of people ask me they ask me
when my specific wake up was or when
your specific wake up was but do you
think there was a cultural or political
moment that really was the hammer that
kind of whacked it and then started to
go in the wrong way I think it's been a
long-standing process I think it's been
growing for a long time I think you
could even trace it back to the 60s when
the left shifts from being interested in
economic issues and the working class
towards being interested in you know the
new left interested in cultural issues
and the problem of advertising and
consumerism and so on and that shift
from being interested in production how
are things produced and who owns them
towards being obsessed with consumerism
why are we always pressured to buy
things and so on and that was a very
important shift from economy and power
towards issues of culture and then that
grows through the 70s and the 80s and it
becomes the dominant theme of the left
and you know the way I see it is that if
I look back because I still call myself
a Marxist libertarian I partly do it
just to we're gonna do it just to annoy
people
because no understands what it means
yeah even I don't understand what he
owns but I always considered the left to
be universal pro-growth that was one of
the most important parts of the left and
interested in autonomy interested in
pushing away all the priests and princes
and and bureaucrats who wanted to tell
ordinary people how to live and trusted
ordinary people more than
experts that's how I saw the left now I
see a left a so-called left that has
abandoned those three things
so it's ditched universalism in favor of
the rabbit-hole of identity politics and
the rabbit-hole of biological difference
or historical difference its ditch the
argument for economic growth in favor of
the cult of environmentalism and this
idea that every single thing we do to
the planet is destructive and maybe we
should rein in growth and homeless
growth and it's ditched the argument for
autonomy and and the shoving aside of
the bureaucrats who want to govern
ordinary people's lives in favor of
Sacre lysing expertise and celebrating
expertise and celebrating the state and
the role of the state in governing or
assisting poor people who apparently
can't cope on their own so if those are
the three spheres of left-wing politics
and I think they are which is
universalism economic growth in order to
liberate people from poverty and the
idea that people can probably run their
own lives and will make a better fist of
it than government would I think that's
what the left used to be about going
back a hundred years 150 years they've
ditched all of that and are now very Pro
stay pro identity Pro division and pro
planet over pro growth that is what
worries me so that's why I say I didn't
leave the left I still consider myself a
man of the radical left yeah it's the
left that is drifted off into a whole
new territory yeah and that's why
whatever whatever it is that we are
whatever that is yeah that thing and we
I don't even know all your political
bleeps on everything but I'm sure we
have some disagreements up but whatever
it is that we basically are is becoming
the widest tent because I see what
happened what's happening right now and
it's like we're taken in people all over
them yes that are just going I just want
to live free you know this is the
exciting thing about the period we live
in this is where I am optimistic and I'm
generally very optimistic about where
politics is going even though it goes up
and down and up and down you know I I
still consider myself a little bit of a
trotskyist right now and the reason when
I say this to right-wing friends of mine
and and kind of classical liberal
friends when they look at me in absolute
horror and then I say to them look
Trotsky was once asked what does it mean
to be a radical leftist and he said it
means you want to increase the power of
man over nature and decrease the power
of man over man
now I would live and die by them yeah
that's pretty good
that is all right I want to increase our
control of nature so that we understand
it better and we use it better in order
to end poverty and so on it's
particularly in the third world and I
want to decrease the power of man over
man fewer laws for your regulations no
censorship no bureaucracy or far less
bureaucracy so when I say that to
classical liberals and right-wing
friends of mine they they get it
instantly yeah but what's really
exciting about today is that I actually
think the new alliances that are forming
are incredibly interesting so I often
find I have far more in common even with
people on the old right or certainly
with people on the kind of classical
liberal right or the free-market right
then I do with people who today describe
themselves as left-wing I have more in
common with the religious people in
Europe who are currently defending
freedom of speech far better than some
atheists are because religious speech is
under attack in Europe so it's the new
alliances that I find incredibly
interesting and exciting and and and so
I think a new dividing line is opening
up and it's no longer the dividing line
between where do you stand on the market
or are you left-wing or right-wing it's
increasingly a dividing line over
do you trust ordinary people to run
their own lives and that sounds like a
simple question but actually cuts to the
heart of everything because if you do
trust ordinary people to run their own
lives you will be interested in
diminishing government interference
defending free speech in all instances
because you think people can make up
their own minds and diminishing
bureaucracy if you don't trust ordinary
people and tragically the left doesn't
anymore you will be in favor of growing
the welfare state growing environmental
controls restricting the expansion of
production and growth and everything
else and censoring speech so the key
dividing line I I think now is
do you trust people yes or no it's such
an interesting distinction you're making
there because the left but if you were
just looking at this sort of from higher
up down what the messaging is it's sort
of like you know you're screwed you're
the little man and you know we so we
really care about you but what they're
really saying is give us power to
control you yeah this is these are two
very different things
and that's why I think so much of what's
happening with post-modernism and
intersectionality and all of this is
just lazy thinking yeah it sounds good
at first like oh you're gonna give more
money to poor people or we're gonna you
know if you are pressed in this way you
should link together with someone who's
oppressed in this way it all sounds kind
of like it makes sense but when you get
to that second layer it starts peeling
away pretty freaking quick this is the
really shocking thing about the left
today the left is now a movement against
working-class people and that is a
turnaround in politics which i think is
historically unprecedented the left used
to be a movement for working-class
people which meant that it understood
them or it sought to understand them it
wanted to know what they thought it
wanted to increase their power and
increase their autonomy and increase
their income that's what the left was
born to do and that's what it devoted
itself to doing for decades increasingly
what the left represents now is it's a
movement against working people so in
Britain in on the British left they now
often refer refer to poor and
working-class people as the vulnerable
and they see them as very vulnerable
people vulnerable to being exploited
vulnerable to the harsh vagaries of
everyday life
vulnerable to the spin-offs of poverty
and so on and so their argument becomes
we must protect these people we must
save these people we must help these
people and what happens then over time
is that they it's less and less about
liberating ordinary people whether it's
from the harshness of everyday life or
from the diktats of bureaucracy and it
becomes more about mollycoddling them
and building this therapeutic
bureaucratic scaffolding around every
single area of
lives and as a consequence these people
have less freedom less choice less sense
of themselves as active citizens in the
world so everywhere I look at the left
now particularly in Britain at Western
Europe and the US I think they are
having an incredibly destructive impact
on ordinary people's lives yeah which is
why I'm you know I still call myself
left-wing but I'm constantly conscious
of the fact that to most people out
there perfectly understandably they
think that means I'm on the wrong side
so maybe I'm fighting a losing battle
yeah I'm going to recover a sense of
what the left used to be yeah I
completely hear you brother
I like that you call that a bureaucratic
scaffolding that because it's just this
sort of fate it's almost as if they've
built this bureaucratic scaffolding on
quicksand yes really
so it's temporarily holding up this
stuff up and controlling you that's are
actually the the foundation is sinking
at the same time but you know what what
proved to me that the left is in the on
the wrong side these days was brexit so
in last year 2016 seventeen point four
million British people the largest
number of British people that have ever
voted for anything in history voted
against the European Union and for
greater sovereignty greater popular
sovereignty greater Democratic control
against the EU which is an institution
which is a liberal undemocratic and also
racist it has a two-tier immigration
policy which allows freedom of movement
for largely white Europeans while at the
same time paying African dictators to
keep their people out of Europe so this
is an institution that I'm absolutely
alarmed but anyone who calls themselves
liberal or left-wing could support this
business bureau cracy and that's exactly
what they did
that's what they did so ordinary people
seventeen point four million of them
defied the advice of the establishment
pretty much the entire establishment was
on their knees begging us to vote to
stay in the European Union they defied
the establishment they voted against
this bureaucracy and they voted by
implication and sometimes explicitly in
what they said to pollsters they voted
for independence for more control over
there
is for less bureaucracy in their lives
right it was an incredibly positive
moment in British history in my view
it's the best thing that's happened in
Britain in 25 years
politically speaking and it was framed
as if it was some sort of racist was
framed
so what you have is the left instantly
denounced it as racist xenophobic a new
form of fascism you people have been
hoodwinked by demagogues you don't know
what you're doing you're low information
this was the term they use low
information voters idiots imbeciles you
stupid people how could you do this that
you know there are many nails in the
coffin of the left I think their failure
to understand the positive progressive
component of brexit might prove to be
the final nail because that was a very
clear instance of people doing the
things that people like us would like
them to do right take a stand against
bureaucracy and and speak for yourself
be self-governing desire to be in
control of your own life that positive
wonderful Enlightenment idea which
informed the left for at least a hundred
years after the Enlightenment and then
bit by bit they kind of lost sight of it
that's what breaks it represented and
the left's response was to call us
because I voted for breaks it was to
call us fascists that is the worst
application of the less historic
responsibility that I can remember
yeah and it's such an interesting way
that they they change words I mean they
change definitions of words fascists
yeah you were the anti fascist yes right
you were trying to take the power away
absolutely yeah
it's just they consistently do this
that's astonishing if you are in favor
of freedom of speech if you think there
should be no controls on speech if you
think democracy is preferable to
technocracy if you think these things
which we traditionally have been seen as
anti-fascist they will now call you a
fascist they've completely bastardized
that word and use it simply as a brand
to denounce people who they dislike and
you know it's particularly pronounced in
the campus culture wars where those who
defend freedom of speech most
vociferously on campus are the ones who
are called fascist which is a complete
reversal of what fascism is I was at the
in Warsaw a few weeks ago at the Museum
of the history of the Jews in Poland
which is a terrible history and what was
amazing is that there's this whole room
devoted to the Warsaw Ghetto where the
Jews were piled in before they were all
exterminated and what's amazing is that
in the Warsaw Ghetto they had no free
speech rights
none whatsoever fascist and the nazis
denied them any free speech rights and
yet these underground networks developed
and and and magazines and newspapers
emerged like mushrooms after the rain in
within the words of one of these people
in the in the warsaw ghetto you know a
risk of death they published their own
magazines they published their own
newspapers in Bunker's they stored them
under floorboards they secretly sold
them on the street and they could be
shot on the spot for doing this no my
view is that anti-fascism is freedom of
speech that's what it is in its entirety
fascism is censorship so it when I hear
all these anti far people and all these
anti-fascists going around demanding the
censorship of people they don't like
demanding the censorship of people who
they find difficult or uncomfortable
they are behaving far more like fascists
they are behaving far more like the
rulers of the Warsaw Ghetto who forbade
Jews from publishing magazines and
newspapers than they are like
anti-fascists and in my mind
anti-fascism by which I mean largely the
left yeah the left was a great warrior
against fascism was entirely about
defending freedom and it was primarily
about defending freedom of thought and
freedom of speech is the inherent
problem here with the anti fast stuff is
that the left whoever the leaders are
whether it's in Britain or in the United
States that they've coddled these ideas
for so long that they don't want to
stand up and say to anti fie you can't
do this because they don't want those
tactics used on them yes so when
everyone's concerned about violence
right now and house you know speech and
violence's are starting to meld together
I mean anti Faiz though if there was one
organization that is creating illegal
violence in the United States the most
at the moment it's anti feh I mean the
one of the most underreported stories of
last year was outside the Democratic
National Committee as Hillary was being
nominee
and if I was basically burning it down
the mainstream media barely showed if
they show up to all these campuses and
burn everything down and break store
windows and all that the right has its
problems and I want to get to that too
because that's where you started here
you're uncomfortable with what we're
we've sort of been shifted to which I
think is really interesting but part of
the issue is the left can't stand up to
these people because they know that
they'll just take them out the way
they've taken out everyone else yeah my
view of anti-fire is that it is
absolutely the most ridiculous movement
I can think of is obscene in fact
because they present themselves as being
in the lineage of people like George
Orwell George Orwell left his incredibly
comfortable life in Britain to go to
Spain and fight physically against
fascists and risk death anti far right
now is actually a very bourgeois anti
working-class anti-democratic movement
which thinks being an anti-fascist means
getting uber into town and punching a
working-class Trump voter in the face
that is incomparable to what the
International Brigades did in Spain or
to what anti-fascists did in Greece
during the Second World War or to what
German citizens did who secretly plotted
and acted against the Nazis to commit
for them to compare compare themselves
to genuine anti-fascists in 20th century
Europe is outrageous in fact this is a
censorious snobby paternalistic
ridiculous bourgeois movement which has
completely lost sight of what it means
to be left-wing and completely lost
sight of what it means to be
anti-fascist to the extent that they
behave far more like fascists than they
do anti-fascists they are censorious
they burn things down that they find
offensive they agitate constantly to
shut down meetings they heckle people so
they cannot be heard you know they
remind me of one of the greatest things
ever written about freedom of speech was
titled a plea for free speech by
Frederick Douglas former slave of course
become abolitionist one of my favorite
figures from American history he took
part in a abolitionist meeting in Boston
and it was shut down by hecklers the
pro-slavery hecklers who invaded this
meeting and prevent
it from taking place Frederick Douglass
was so shocked by this that he wrote a
plea for free speech in which he said
free speech is the most important
freedom in the world and it's the
freedom that make makes tyrannies
tremble it's the freedom that puts
government on the backfoot it's the
freedom that keeps you as a citizen free
and active and puts authority back in
the closet where they belong
away from us and that was an argument
against the kind of thing but anti far
is doing which is invading meetings
preventing them from taking place a very
informal mob like form of censorship so
that's what they remind me off from
history they remind me of these
right-wing borderline fascistic very
questionable agitators who hated the
idea of people having freedom who hated
the idea of people speaking freely and
listening freely so the idea that anti
far is an in in any way progressive or
liberal or decent is a joke yeah all
right sort of wrap this sort of hole
first chunk together I want to talk
about this right and part of this
because you said you're sort of
uncomfortable with how this connects to
the right or where you suddenly find
yourself allied yes
yeah it's not that I'm not uncomfortable
to the extent that I can't cope with it
and one of the problems I think among
left wingers who are libertarian and I
include myself in that number I think
too sometimes they are so terrified of
being called right-wing that they
actually will end up ditching their own
principles so they won't defend free
speech as much as they would like to
because they know they'll be called
they'll be compared with Cato or reason
or some other group that they are a bit
questionable about so it's not that I'm
uncomfortable to the extent that I am
going to ditch my principles I would
never ever ditch the argument for
freedom of speech I think that's the key
thing everyone has to do in the 21st
century but it's simply that I think the
reason the right has managed to colonize
the argument for liberty today in
particular the argument for freedom of
speech is not because they are 100%
behind it and you can see that in the
way in which they will agitate agitate
against the right of his lamas to
speak on campus or you know they will be
quite favorable of punishing Beyonce for
example for doing her black power dance
at the Super Bowl which in Breitbart got
very angry about and demanded an apology
for we think calm down Breitbart yeah
I'm pretty sure Beyonce doesn't do a
power yeah she doesn't do this and
that's great it's it's so they're not a
hundred percent on the side of freedom
of speech but the reason they can appear
to be is because the left has abandoned
the field and the left has turned
freedom into a dirty word and the left
has given the impression that freedom is
a right wing project this is the great
historic mistake that the left has made
it is so thoroughly abandoned the
argument for freedom of speech and for
liberty in general and for individual
autonomy which Chile used to be a
central part of radical left-wing
politics going back 150 years or so it's
so thoroughly abandoned that that the
right can now step in and say well we
are the masters of this argument so the
left has totally screwed things up and
granted the moral high ground to people
right right
so basically by not playing they've just
ceded the game
seesee okay so I understand that and I
feel you're probably you're probably
right in that but what I also found at
the exact same time is that as I've had
my own journey here and talking to
people all over the mat that I find a
lot more intellectual flexibility with
people on the right yeah so if I sit I
can sit across from people that are
pro-life while I'm pro-choice or even
some people that are against gay
marriage and I I'm gay married or you
know that I'm against the death penalty
and therefore definitely they'll at
least have an intellectual argument
about it and I see much less of that on
the left well the perfect example of
this I was supposed to speak at Oxford
University in 2014 on abortion and it
was two men it was me on one side making
the pro-choice argument I'm about as
pro-choice as you can get I mean the
other side was a right-wing man from The
Daily Telegraph which is a right-wing
newspaper who was going to make the anti
choice or pro-life argument feminists
Oxford shut it down they said it was
unacceptable for people without uterus
which is how they described us which I
thought was quite transphobic talk about
biology in that way should we tell
people
now the biologically or a woman exactly
the red jacket oh yeah I should
self-identify they threatened to shut it
down they threatened to turn up with
instruments and they didn't mean musical
instruments to prevent this debate from
taking place and Oxford too it's
mortifying shame a grid of them and
prevented the debate from taking place
what that told me was here was this
right-wing guy who's very anti choice
thinks abortion is terrible who was
willing to discuss with me and I am
incredibly pro-choice I mean right up to
the end because I believe in bodily
individual autonomy he was willing to
have that incredibly difficult debate
with me whereas the so-called left on
the campus the so called Oxford radicals
didn't want the debate to take place at
all so I think you're right at the
moment on the right there is more
intellectual flexibility there's more
openness there's more honesty and if I
was coming of political age now I would
probably go to the right and I think
that's where lots of sensible people are
going and I perfectly understand why
[Music]
you